[Music]
here's a set I imagine was a little
different to work on him talking about
the Fifty Shades films the third and
final installment Fifty Shades freed
whoops into theaters next week and we've
got your exclusive behind-the-scenes
Anastasia I solemnly vow to love you
faithfully billionaire bad-boy Christian
gray and his love Anastasia Steele
finally tie the knot after their rather
kinky courtship took my wife
[Music]
the pair jet off to a romantic honeymoon
in Paris and seems they had a lot of fun
last night on Jimmy Kimmel Live Jamie
Dornan seemed to hint about Dakota
Johnson's new romance with Coldplay's
Chris Martin when talking about his own
working relationship with his new lady
it's almost like brother-sister no but
we just you know cuz I am married and
you know she's had quite a lot of
relationships in the time that we've
known each other you just have this sort
of mutual love and respect for each
other elsewhere besides the risque
romance there's a stalker who kidnaps
and ties up grace sister Rita Ora and it
wouldn't be a fifty Shades movie without
all the sensual love scenes and the
naughty red play room hey want to play
yes sir they love each other in such an
aggressive way that it becomes
possession
you